I've come together with the one on my
charity which is 100 donation policy and
do amazing work around the world this
winter brother sisters helped to feed
those who are in poor conditions and who
don't even have a clothing to keep
theirself warm your small donation might
mean nothing to you but it can change
their life and help them survive the
winter this year
um you were reacting to Muslim women who
were talking about their experiences
with polygamy every man we're talking
about men yeah you're an almost a man
I'm a Muslim man so the thing is every
man man is polygamous by Nature what
Islam does is send protocols to tell you
how to do it in a proper way but you
don't abuse the other wife you know why
because
women do this as well they have side
chicks Mistresses and girlfriends so
Islam says no if you're gonna do it you
do it the right way you want another
woman you honor her you speak to her
father no having I'll get whatever I
want and I'll Chuck you to decide no no
you marry you honor you give her a
wedding you provide and protect for her
and I believe any woman in their right
mind if they're feminist they will be
properly all day every day when you were
arguing with that woman who um she was a
feminist but also a Muslim is that right
yes she didn't ascribe if she had some
feministic views you know yeah well that
was the title yeah it made for a good
title yeah it worked and um you said
look
it did make me laugh I've got a bit he
said if you want me to stand in front of
you when we're getting attacked by some
guy with a knife yes then you better
look after me in the bedroom well
exactly you know why because this is
exactly what we're seeing because
remember I said the greatest inequality
is to treat unequal things equally so
the thing is here I'm at my most
vulnerable when it comes down we studies
that show when it comes to intimacy now
as Muslim men we are not allowed to
sleep around meaning that we even
thought Allah says in the Quran tell the
believing mental or his gaze meaning if
I go out and I see a woman dressed
inappropriately appropriately I don't
keep sweating in a cup hijab or a bikini
I have to look away so I am protecting
myself from that with the with the Gaze
yeah so and then afterwards I'm going
out working for my for my family going
out there come on man look at the rent
prices
and then you're going through all of
that you're coming home and by the way
um she doesn't she doesn't want to she
doesn't have to but what I'm saying is
then I will get another wife how about
that so then oh no I don't want that
well then hold on a second that's
Freedom of Choice then well well that's
fine but what I'm saying
no no
no no she was you know what she was
saying she was saying lawyer gaze to
your wife don't look at her um go
masturbate
um and I was thinking well hold on a
second let's reverse it you're you're on
the road somebody puts a knife out
imagine me saying I choose not to defend
you I don't have to you will be losing
your mind the families will be
protesting in front of my house yeah